hi guys rejects friends I'm Greg I'm
John listen we're gonna get this over
and done with quickly all right
I was hoping we're gonna get blown up of
requests unfortunately we did why
because we have not seen the original
ghost in the shell' I actually own it on
Amazon video but I still have not taken
the time to actually watch the damn
thing I want to see I want to see it too
i always saw the VHS box at blockbuster
growing up and I really yeah I mean so
many people request that we do this so
we'll check it out I did not care to be
one of the first ones to get this one up
when you're one of those guys who hasn't
seen the original just kind of looks bad
you know and if anybody cares about how
he comes across and looks it's
definitely me all right Scarlett
Johansson whoa that's cool
oh yeah I'm super so this looks so cool
whoa they're not invulnerable maybe next
time you can design me better
cocky [ __ ] everyone around me I feel
connected to something
connected to something
damn you were dying
you
I have a past
find out
that's pretty cool
everything they told you was a lie who
are you
they did not save your life these
dollars but that ending scene was like a
nice treat for fans of the anime you
know what's going on that's like a half
and a half where I'm like I kind of wish
I didn't see that but I also don't know
what it is
hey I don't know the anime I feel like
everyone's in an uproar about this
goddamn thing awesome oh yeah yeah for
someone who doesn't know any prior
knowledge that looks awesome yeah yeah
if you don't know I don't know what all
the uproars are about there are certain
things where like if you remove yourself
from the fact that you know Scarlett
Johansson super white as a movie this
looks [ __ ] awesome like this is a
sheen worth taking I don't think she
needs to be white based off the story
yeah I know it's a robot Japanese I mean
yeah she they were saying that she's
formerly human then they turned her into
this like Android and yeah it's it's not
a factory gadget means one yeah it might
not be necessary it's just one of those
like why do it you know why change it
what do you need - well whose give us
some more seats
skål Johansson or Sandra oh one Asian
actress we could have gotten that she
could play chun-li in the first Street
Fighter with jean-claude Van Damme
there's now an agents of shield oh oh
yeah what's her name Michelle Kwan
that's a figure skater Tila Tequila I'm
kidding you know I've been I've been
very vocal by my support for Asians
besides I know she's not the Asian
actress in Asia it's yeah plenty of
Asian characters in there yeah there's
not another white dude but whatever
watching this trailer though it got me
pumped you know like I think the matrix
had inspiration from ghost in the shell'
so to say this looks like in the matrix
would kind of just have a lot of
comments or Blade Runner oh yeah yeah
totally super futuristic like towering
metropolis but it looks like an anime
brought to life and the coolest kind of
wait not like an annoying Speed Racer
kind of vibe but in something where it's
like man they have those cool slow-mo
shots or it's very clear it's going on
in the
framing of everything is excellent this
looks like an anime to scope the visual
aesthetic it looks [ __ ] beautiful
yes I'm totally on board oh it looks
like a great time yeah these things
would have been you know these things
are arguably ought to change but just as
a movie just judging it as its own
microcosm it looks breathtaking and with
the whiskers Johansson's working like
Lucy and Black Widow I think this is a
perfect role for her like seeing what
they're doing here why do I do give me
that this skin is now is lots of light
yeah I thought she was making a painting
about Scarlett Johansson is she naked no
she ain't but it's a little I mean this
is like a like some of this is like
twelve-year-old fantasy stuff I'm
excited to get this kind of movie again
and the more time passes you know we
have stuff like Watchmen and and this is
one of them where people are like it's
unfilmable don't touch it but if this
trailer is any indication it seems like
we're gaining ground on the stuff that's
unfilmable just the strength of the
design and I've seen like images from
ghost in the shell' I've seen pictures
and things like that it looks like
they're they're really like you said
bothering to immerse in the sort of
anime hues and visual aesthetics yeah
the one thing that's sure there's not
fully giving me is what is the exact
tone of this film you know right now
they're made they made a really cool
trailer with John's favorite thing in
the world when they put a cover over it
because they know it's like it's funny
to me no because like it's almost like
it's a checklist yeah gotta have one
he's working on some trailers like do it
or not cuz ya know it's like it's
working on all of them now cuz I can't
remember one of these in recently I mean
this could be really cool if it does
have sort of that really haunting like
you know that like uncomfortable eerie
Blade Runner tone yeah something like
that would be cool with this awesome
sci-fi action epic you know again
judging by this stuff it looks like the
actions gonna be [ __ ] awesome to
behold but it also looks like there will
be some some space in between yes you
have all those long shots and it seems
like she's probably not a very
okay I think the premise is cool - yeah
I think that's a really cool premise I
could see why it's being remade yeah
this is giving me hints enjoy the
original ones a classic yeah this made
me want to go like I want to see the
aridity originally the anime looks
anything like this that would be [ __ ]
[ __ ] sweet yeah and all I'm thinking
is like I just hope they nail it cuz the
thing is I'm looking at this trailer and
I'm like there's gonna be stuff about
this that I would be astonished if it
wasn't just as cool as this is this
certainly looks like everything's gonna
be really cool and now I'm just
wondering how good of an adaptation it's
gonna it just needs a certain style in
its tone you know not just the visual
style but a style in the way it's tone
is done - yeah I'm waiting to see if
this is an almost or if this is a nailed
it this could be like a immersive
experience there's kind of like a creepy
backdrops with this whole thing which I
really enjoy yeah it does have a sense
of dread yeah and a detachment you know
is Sylvester Stallone Judge Dredd I know
whose is Rob Schneider there you go
whoa whose is if we had that question on
the movie trivia Schroeder I get that
one if you said it all the time I would
have been so pissed I know you I know
Rob Schneider's in that movie like the
back of my pinky I don't know why I get
I don't know why that one trips me I
don't have to think about yeah this
review is done if you're new to the
channel you didn't subscribe today John
yeah I know I made this movie do we know
uh Trisha Takanawa
bye we'll find out I'm before we end the
video who made this movie by the
originals 22 years old oh it's that guy
yeah oh then you know this movie's gonna
be perfect that's
hey I mean some of those how to destroy
angels music videos are pretty sweet too
but yeah well now I'm kind of worried
because I hated the wagons like is this
gonna look amazing or it is just going
to be almost like it's no I don't know
it was one of those movies where you're
like visually cool but kind of dull man
that's what I'm worried about now but I
don't know I have been saying 11 chairs
got to be [ __ ] sweet well guys if
you're new to the channel subscribe
today yeah trying to do the super finger
that's hard subscribe today become a
reject John his reason to Jerry on his
Twitter and Instagram handle and you
could follow his work on real rejects
and bloom houses Facebook sites